yo is bootleg Capcom and we are in
Austin Texas
fresh off to the independent powerhouse
tour 2016 we're its yield rich are
getting tattooed you got the CNT what if
I tell that to a bomb on me sound leaves
from American affiliate then look at
that thing look out fresh that little CT
man so let me ask you the CNC thing I
you got a hold in line now yeah so
people can buy Ritz's clothing line yeah
yeah all right now I'm gonna love you
know who doesn't have any as me so [__]
you yeah yes 1395 for this comes true
dick I got you I got you it to 14 oh my
gosh I got your home
I get it [__] so I tell you what we
got I mean some shoelaces for you what
do you got for me
you guys are old now but but yet client
self-loathing I got AI got a great juice
now maybe a little bit not I'm not vegan
see you got a fake juice and you're
getting into the entrepreneur space
quite quite nice I'm trying to mend
things with clientele it's like you know
when I started in 95 all my boys were
part of clientele and everybody's got a
name for their fan base you know it's
like for me it's like we're client tells
us if you [__] with me you love the
client so crew that's what I'm trying to
push to everybody like you know so
that's basically what it is public
spending clientele just means you know
we're all connected we all do business
together and well-connected for a while
with myself
C&C to the DMV so look top of the line
is the third album yeah really to me the
fourth album because I consider white
lies but you made the best decision of
your entire life and you let me do a
skit on the album about the dog for that
it soon as I best help you ever put out
star power
Wow not a surprise probably going to
give me some sales listen with bullet
Kevin I do appreciate I heard about it
the records in and I the one thing I
appreciate about you I always say how
big of a fan I am of what you do and
you've always kept it you have never
steered too far off of what we love
about you right or the new album is
vintage R it's [__] yeah it's fitting
you know it's like a fine line you don't
want to sound the same every time right
well if you want to figure out a
different every time you have a good in
the bar so you just want to win - I know
if you want to hear for me not only that
I just I know what type of wrap around
and what type of music I'm making I've
become comfortable with that so this one
I had a vision and that's why the cover
look spin it's a lot of it's super
vintage cover yeah a lot of beats on
here like vintage but they all bang a
lot of instruments and just cool sound
you know I told her so the producer
seven I said I wanted to sound like a
Bruce Lee soundtrack I've been on the
dragon over top of down south drum beats
not all of us like that but he
understood exactly what I'm saying so
like the intro top of the line really
set it off and honestly of course every
artist says is I think it's my best work
there's 24 records a lot of record it's
a lot of Records you know I don't drop
it to that often I really went in
I went through a lot of different types
of [__] on this and I think people are
gonna enjoy it you know you start you do
roll outs you know how artisans roll
outs of you know singles it doesn't give
you a full grasp until you actually
clear that out and then once you hear
that so on the album you got a lot of
features obviously got the strange music
family yeah yeah I've got tech MJ cheese
on the album Devin the Dude and Mike
Posner was in collaborator first of all
Devin to do them JD first Devin a dude
is one of the reasons per month for the
way I rap what it goes underrated it's a
senator I've set him in thing my hair
said in an interview this syllable play
like some people sleep on it but like
pretty genius you know some people slip
on our sleep on our Tupac syllable play
like simple syllable play these two good
grabs like you know and never the dude
was a great rapper and then and for
people that don't recognize that I just
think they don't have it here for rap
music now MJG his flow I believe is
responsible for maybe 15 years of
southern artists the way they departed
regime is I hae an Eightball as well or
my egg Rovers don't like Jesus oh yeah
where's eachother m2g was high you know
on the song par so yeah and of course my
clones were my posers got the [__] it's
so crazy Chris it's like my kind of
cooled out for a while as far as like
his buzz yeah you guys develop the dope
working relationship and now he's got a
top five song
country yeah it's 200 million streams on
Spotify listen what's not in and you
guys are both releasing and have on the
same day well first let's not forget
that you introduced being in my program
yes I did a lot of a lot of the records
a lot of the records that I've got it
might better you know thanks to you you
know and it might just a great guy to be
completely honest man I got denied
single rights for the for the record
yeah left the last album no this out
like like oh yeah that is true and that
he went in like the new song I reached
out to Mike and Mike was like let me
handle it Mike you didn't have to do
that medicine side of the group my
sample there right he's a great guy
then when you say denied single rights
for normal people what does that mean so
what it means was so you can have a song
that says like okay this is gonna be my
regular signal but it then if that
artist label is not allowing this is
right now okay yeah it's a wrap and then
so so people don't understand that so
like Carl Mike went and went to bathroom
me to the label and uh it's nice a great
guy and then me and you and you know
this we talked about it might be in hot
one time and then in being off the radar
for a second though might've been right
written what he called sugar for my
monster i yeah it's amazing he's an
incredible guy seasoned guy and just one
of my Selatan underrated artists nice
person man so like we had a great record
chopped to Eve forty men having the oh
yes that on my record and he's forty has
been one of the most relevant record
you've been able to stay relevant for
years years who's done that it's it's
crazy because it's like really like
talking like late eighties early
nineties it's like even too short I mean
think about this is your shortlist 8:40
is oh gee and got a lot of pool in the
game and I didn't get me 40 on it
because he stays well if I got hit 40 on
it because it's in 40 know you've always
told me um as I asked you talk like what
are you listening to who influences you
and like for the most part you don't
listen to nothing except for the [__]
you like yeah yeah the old [__] that you
loved like oh I listen to some new
represent right now and then what are
some of the new rappers that you
appreciate that you know if you don't my
fans get really upset man you know I'm
each other I try to go for the best so I
listen to Drake and drink is incredible
I really think little Wayne is probably
one of the best rappers I think at the
end of the day when people realize what
he brought to the game I know his style
has changed over the years but I think
Lil Wayne is one of the best rappers of
all time is you a project would you
change this dope - yeah yeah to change
the street I mean as far as there's so
many new rappers that are out there I
mean I got homies that you know that are
my type of playing field that do they
think - right there's a ton of rappers
out there that are really graphic
these days but um you know I stick with
the whole school man you know I like you
know I like what I like and it's hard to
change that now my outcasts got Ryan
Parker did you watch the organized Royce
documentary that's been out just got
really solid
no it's on it just got put on Netflix I
know you're on the road if you got time
to watch it yeah oh yeah well I will
shout to organized if you got the ATM in
ten yeah that they Gillian's pretend
that under you cover it up listen I know
you're trying to get big boy on this
side I'm trying to get big boy for the
next albums we got to make it happen
big boy the guilt with deal comes from
you you know that this is a big boys
trademark with yup you know I just put
together in front of it and you know I
was such a big fan and I'm sound think
there's a fresher rapper than me quit
like when you look at fresh snow for
sure - so fly man and when I was a kid I
just wanted to be like him so to have
big boy on a regular one day I hope that
happens we haven't made it happen you
know you're going through these albums
with ideas of who you want his features
and nine times out of 10 they don't
happen so you got a scramble for okay
looming
and then everybody's idea you know from
a labels point of view or a radio point
of view you want to get the hot bag
right but for me I want to get somebody
to influence me so it's like but some of
the older guys that enforce me you know
that this burned out on the game you
know so it's it's it's a fine line
trying to figure out who could get in
speeches you know and fans have
expectations too so you're getting
married soon
you have game marry house house planning
a wedding going for you they've stood
men I'm talking take some CEO a lot of
crowd there's gonna be a cowboy okay it
we're gonna have Crown Royal plus I
should call the guests well gifts yeah
give some gift bags yellow crown role
with personal labels on it
just cool and then I'm excited about
it's about time we did another for ten
years
tell your parents um it's time to grow
up you know it took me a long time you
know you know a lot of people look at me
and really my rap career we put this
real simple real fast I was a [__]
studio head and rap forever that never
had no education I put rap and got a job
I took serious got lucky that do a
yellow of in bass attraction and every
time I keep making a little bit more
money just enough to like okay I bought
my first part in the house I can get
married may be nice to my
maybe they somebody have enough to buy a
house people just automatically think
you just kidding and you're just you and
it's not like that man you know and
that's the reality of it so I can't
complain them and I'm living good and
humble obstacle I'm blessed man me I
know off of your craft yeah man no
bootleg keV it's a [__] famous person
this [__] guy this guy's a [__]
maniac but not not quite as much with
maniacs races you know the one thing
that I like I like that always drew me
to you initially I think the first well
obviously the first thing I heard was a
black Chevy
Yesha that was the first time I ever
heard you
and then the first solo record I heard
it was it wasn't I think it was it was
either high fiber or was smashed
potatoes mashed potatoes shop to DJ burn
one and I was I was hooked on
automatically and then white Jesus
dropped and I think I got you on the
phone like right away and directed just
honesty in the music is
you know you're talking about nowhere to
run was one record to cut through
convenient and just your openness about
the truck you do because it is cuz I can
look man like I just I was growing up
around couple family people who do
[__] do this [__] that you rap about
doing that nobodies we're talking about
doing and it's just like this game has
there ever been a time where that type
of should have bit you in the ass
like um not so far but you know to be
honest I guess the only thing is yeah I
want to do a cooking show and they look
back at some of my content or if I want
to do certain things they look back I
saw my content just being honest I've
always said today when did with this new
album and so I show my so much more
vulnerability and and we talked about
this before some of the some of the ways
when I first came up if I would have
done a video for nowhere to run or Oh
they've been different you know but I
didn't have money back then to do it so
it's like if they can choose we had to
pick and choose man you know high five I
was one of my biggest record but she did
a video but we didn't have the money you
know so now I did it I did it I finally
did a deep record I know wishing that a
video comes to be record but this one I
got a I got a song on my window on my
new album is a deep red I've got a video
for it and you know our show my
vulnerability man yeah I think it's very
important I think that's what people
respect about me is that you know
speaking of in that hole in that you
know sense speed of respect let
everybody know how many how many hours
is RIT sold independently two albums
deep how many happens episode
over on mm over a hotdog it's two hours
independently and it still seems like
without crazy major but it just it's
like it just still seems like I'm here
you're not you kind of study inter this
inspector deserves me yeah you know I
mean you know sometimes like it bothers
me sometimes the only reason what
maintance about is me instead I just
want people to hear the music because
our practice so hard on being great so I
think the more I deserved from other
people to hear it
the sods are many records are so and
strange music has done a great job at
pushing it for what they do you know
exam but yeah I do so like that should
be bigger okay you've had radio hits
yeah I'm out having nice that alone I
feel like you've had songs that should
have hit on the
we feel better I don't know whose fault
it is that they did it but you know
obviously you got a great record on this
list inside the group right here in some
of the groups which again is something
nice yeah man but as far as um we were
just talking about
obviously yeah how many records you have
with my closing the file going on I
think five oh five counting one
unreleased right so yeah five with my
close enough
maybe we should you should got them to
the heaven that face you should color
Graham in the arc Jason are you that you
Mike yeah the best of both worlds let's
do it yeah Mike what's up with you how
how how is our your new old relationship
today wolf has a great heart and you're
sure wolf is are done a lot for me it
just man the thing is like this I put up
my track listing for for my album and a
lot of fans like who yellow yellow
yellow yellow
I said yellow with three tracks and say
yo I want you on the song pull up he
just ignored it just wrote to whatever
song you wanted right - and we talked
about so he wrote to Psalm propane which
I had already had dairy and energy and
what people are saying I would put the
woofers on it but a song can only be
under five minutes or starts want to get
you publishing so it was what it was you
know that's what the remix out on
soundcloud yeah yeah yeah and also man
so man wolf I was I was it - I always
you know look look to him for guidance
and you know we'll talk every day but
it's one of those things like I could
not talk to you every day were cynical
people so uh whoops a great guy man and
his career is doing great and I think he
found that space just like I'm finding
my lane
he's found who he isn't comfortable with
who he is and he's doing better than
these Bend on because he's in him will
we ever see Ritz in a pair of cowboy
boots no no I don't know I'm just [__]
but yeah if you see me in a fair cowboy
boots don't look like ya I'm not gonna
look this cool if I look like I'm 50
years I look like that damn garage any
Rogers oh but listen listen let me make
this clear real quick this guy doesn't
give himself enough respect like like
without giving himself enough enough
props let me give him some props bootleg
Kev's introduce me to lift it Mike
Posner been a big part of my career so
thank you man let's make it clear let's
make that clear the top of mine is
coming out May 6 topping line coming out
May 6 best body work so far best body of
work 24 records I mean come on man all
these people to say oh rich left the
same when everywhere get no
[__] you need to list you know
it all these things are switched up
different rhyme schemes different topics
in different styles yo what's with
anybody who listens to you bro it's like
every time they listen to like like I
could listen to a record of here's the
first 30 times and each time I hear
something different that I'm in
detention right the time before and
that's why I'm just such a big fan you
look like you could like that they're
listening power of by Kelvin wait a
minute
or the tent-like dam and it's one thing
to chop but it's another thing to
actually say so yeah and I don't think
that's work I think Brian Tech's black
over my lyrics I think that a lot of
people don't appreciate what I put into
the chopping they can't distinguish a
chopper that says I got a patent to up
and you back to tough and I gotta map it
up and grab a button man you know I have
a gun I stand up and pray like I don't
do that I figure out I take the 30
minutes to see what rhymes with plastic
cup besides act to know about horn
around act and all the plants and
thought that's the person Decatur my
head nobody respects that they don't
understand that I try to do that and I
might go you know different rhyme
schemes but something was ear is not
that intricate truth so so for me when I
test that flag it really is hard for me
not to come in batlike [__] I
put in so much time to be better than
these guys that fast I'll get it's real
you know anyone come on thinking that
drinking the second there's someone
worse you know you do and I discussed in
Arizona about a month and a half ago for
those people
you'll write some boom-bap type regular
rap yes maybe a potential mix think I
have I know you've written these raps I
I know that you told me how incredible
they are they're cool the cool and so
just is that something that's for people
don't know what we're talking about is
obviously people don't rich for chopping
over a certain type of instrumental and
right you wrote some sub records that
world where babies the 90 by BPM Batman
is nitrogen dark some dark like New York
that packed and so you've written a
bunch of stuff right yeah and hey you
know what minutes that's how I always
rap before before I found my niche in
the double-time thing is I mean you
better VT hip-hop Awards know I can rap
then like I it's not I just don't do one
thing and a lot of and I just you know I
want to display that sometime but not
this I even want to go all the way like
if I'm here with a dumb town and the
school records I'm gonna go over here
and do some [__] for free Diaz boom
bap and like really come on there with
lyrics and write really strong so I
don't know okay it might be something
that season like that hopefully that'll
see the light of day the surface I it's
gonna suit a lot of data surface it's
all about time go get the album may 6
and be out on iTunes or be in stores
sort of be out at night that's fine
that's why we'll have the deluxe version
with all 25 records on it that's why
I'll have that it's a double disc and
then also tonight obviously is available
open line clientele clothing is fine so
cool calm you can also get clients
elevate Jews I stopped smoking
cigarettes I I'm not big into the baby
culture but it's helped me out a lot
with my breath on
I don't believe this help me so I put
out my own feet juice with PVC liquids
over it's around me unable to you lashes
matter power low it's go wrong there's
no wrong hot [__] it's still rolling
let's wrap it up welllook go get his
[__] album May 6 type of the line I
am lucky enough to be on it I feel very
privileged and honored who's my favorite
rapper go shouts my brother Ritz shots
my boy go buy some of your [__] in this
[__] were cnc ye fresh